-Welcome back.
-Hello! Thank you.
I love coming to your show.
-I love having you here.
And I also love that "The Voice"
is coming back.
-Yes.
♪♪ La Voix ♪♪
[ Both laugh ]
-"La Voix," that's right.
-I can't not do it.
-So, this is your second season.
You won your first season.
-I did.
-Did you get to brag it up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was one of those things --
Well, Blake and I made a bet.
If I won, he had to call me
Queen Kelly Clarkson.
And if he won, I'd have
to shut up for five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm still talking.
No, but so --
I mean, I had to perform
at his bar to get him to say it,
but, yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-So in order for him
to call you Queen,
you had to, like, go do a gig.
-I had to go to Ole Red.
That's what I had to do.
But I was willing to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Hopefully you got some
nice grainy iPhone video
of him calling you Queen.
-I do have grainy --
[ Both laugh ]
-They just released
a clip online,
I think either
yesterday or today,
of this wonderful 13-year-old...
-13, yeah.
-...who's got this
incredibly powerful voice.
-Yeah.
-And it seemed like,
based on the way
you guys were talking,
and this will obviously
be in the show
when it premieres, but you guys
were all blown away.
-We were.
We all kind of took our time
turning around, too, 'cause...
Well, we were first
all blown away that she was 13.
And then, when you turn around
and you even noticed it,
you can tell she's young
but not that young.
But still, even if we thought
she was like 16,
we thought, "God,
your voice is so lived in."
-When she said she was 13,
I believe you
got out of your chair
and went and walked around.
-I was -- 'Cause then
you picture yourself at 13.
-Yeah.
-And you're like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
I -- What?
-Yeah.
I still was, like,
braces, acne, glasses.
There was a lot going on,
like, and she's...
She's beautiful, as well.
-Is it against the rules --
Do they tell you
never get out of your chair?
Is that a big thing?
-I'm gonna get fined
a lot of money.
-Is it like
an airplane situation
where you're not allowed
to get up or anything?
-No, I think they love
when I get up and hit Blake.
[ Laughter ]
I think they welcome that.
-You are going on tour
in January.
-Yes.
-And you're going on tour
with last year's winner, right?
-Brynn Cartelli
and Kelsea Ballerini.
-That's fantastic.
She's wonderful.
I love having her here.
-Whole Lotta Woman --
that's like the tour, man.
There's a lot of women.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And she's 15.
-Yeah, yeah, she just turned --
She was 14 on the season.
Adam was actually like,
"Can 13-year-olds audition?"
We were like, "What?"
But, yeah, it's incredible.
And Brynn is --
It's cool about
our tour because --
I was kind of nervous
'cause I'm like,
"Whoa, that's a lot of females,"
but then it was like,
we bring something
so different to the stage.
-Sure.
-And how our production is
and how we're
gonna see that through.
It's so different.
And it's just -- I don't know.
I think you get to an age, too,
where you love
just hanging out with people
you love.
You want to work
with people you love.
-And she's --
-Which is why I'm here, Seth.
-Oh, thank you.
-I love you.
-So, here's Brynn hanging out
with your daughter, River.
-Yes.
-And looks like --
River's getting it
pretty good there.
That's like a mini concert.
-She --
Well -- [ Chuckles ]
Until she told Brynn,
"Shh. It's River's turn.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, really?
-And then she serenaded Brynn.
-Oh, wow.
So River
has a lot of confidence.
-She has a lot
of confidence issues. No.
No, she's just really bold,
and she loves people.
And Brynn
was laughing so hard at that.
-And your son's name is...?
-Remy.
And he's drumming in the car.
-That's great.
And then, uh --
-And then there's Henry.
-Henry your dog, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Who can't see.
His hair.
I couldn't
get him a haircut yet.
-Do you --
When you go on tour in January,
will the kids come with you?
-Yes.
I mean, all four
usually come out at some point,
but the two younger ones
are pretty much with me.
They're in school now,
but it's like a weekend thing,
so, yeah,
they'll probably come out.
And our 11-year-old
goes on stage sometimes.
-What's that?
-Our 11-year-old goes on stage.
Seth has been on stage
on one tour with me.
-And does he just wander on,
or is it planned?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
He's so funny.
He goes and like
high-fives the ladies,
and he's like, "They love me."
[ Laughter ]
He's, like, ama--
None of our kids
suffer from confidence --
It comes honestly.
-Yeah, exactly.
Do you introduce him
when he comes out on stage?
-Yeah.
No, he came out --
Well, it's funny
'cause we started with
my background singers.
They were like,
"Yeah, you can stand with us."
And then he like,
after the one time was like,
"So what song am I singing next?
Can I go out on the team?"
He's hilari--
But he's actually really good.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah, yeah.